[Music]
as every day passes this relief
operation gets more and more urgent and
desperate
afghans hoping to escape have to walk
through ranks of taliban fighters
the british military are trying to move
thousands of people out of afghanistan
in just days
it's a humanitarian mission in what
feels like a war zone
a makeshift barricade is all that
separates two armies who have fought for
20 years the taliban are just one meter
away it's a picture i never thought i
would ever see
this is the first day that they've been
able to bring order here
we've watched as thousands converged on
this base threatening to overwhelm the
whole evacuation
the taliban have assisted in this
up the road they're now controlling the
crowds of people trying to reach the
british position
sometimes they fire into the air to make
people stop
but they are a continuously menacing
presence
well this is a humanitarian effort but
it's being done by the military because
we're effectively in a war zone and
what's incredible
just one step away
there's a taliban right next to the
british
forces who are trying to assess the
people who are trying to get onto these
relief flights
as one of the soldiers said to me they
could mess this up by just sending a
thousand blokes down the road at the
moment
they're cooperating and uh they're
actually keeping things calm
it looks like chaos but there is a
the
method
call out for interpreters as different
nationalities arrive
[Music]
their paperwork is then checked
if they pass muster they're directed to
the entry gate to be processed inside
but many do not
the soldiers hate this but without the
proper paperwork they have to turn
people away
you've got this
terrified families men women and large
numbers of children are sent back
back into afghanistan
back towards the taliban
and it's heartbreaking
fatima is terrified
her husband joined the taliban and took
to beating her
she and her four-year-old daughter have
nothing but a u.n letter identifying
them as victims
[Music]
[Music]
we mentioned her story to the officer in
charge outside
the soldiers have a reasonable degree of
latitude in their decision-making and
major steve white decided to enter her
into the system with no guarantees
it was quite simply an act of human
kindness
in all this mayhem
fatima did make it inside
[Music]
major white may have saved their lives
he's certainly given them a chance of a
better one but there are many sad
stories as well
i'm too sure that they will kill us
this doctor from her rat who is with her
sister and her mother have absolutely no
rights to get through the gates
they fled the taliban and are now stuck
they have hope but it seems hopeless we
don't have any brother we don't have
father you know that
living in here is very difficult for us
we were living in gerard and we escaped
from herald and came to kabul city
to save our life because also my anchors
worked with the taliban and they wanted
to
oblige us to force marriage and also i'm
a doctor and my sister worked was
working with the woman right she
steadily lie and ma also my mother is a
teacher my mother was the teacher of
students in eighth class the voice that
taliban doesn't they don't let her to
teach the boys and now
she doesn't work my mom so now you're
running away really
yes yes we escaped escape from our place
these soldiers are involved in a mission
as diametrically opposed to anything
they could ever have expected in
afghanistan
the taliban have won here
in 20 years a generation has grown up
knowing what the taliban were like they
don't want the next generation to
experience it
once again
a small contingent of soldiers are
dealing with the mess
mr ramsey sky news kabul